Modelele de programare sunt specificații fundamentale care definesc
cum este structurat software-ul
și executat — ele oferă un cadru
pentru dezvoltatori să exprime algoritmi
și să organizeze codul, ascunzând adesea detaliile de nivel scăzut
ale hardware-ului de bază sau ale mediului de execuție
diferite modele sunt potrivite pentru diferite tipuri de probleme
și arhitecturi hardware, oferind
niveluri variate de abstractizare
și control — în acest capitol
vom trece în revistă modelele de programare cuantică și clasică
și vom vedea cum le putem combina pentru a opera algoritmi
în
vom începe cu modelul de programare
pentru un calculator cuantic — un model de programare fundamental
care le este familiar aproape tuturor dezvoltatorilor cuantici
este quantum circuit — nu vom intra
în detaliile quantum circuit-urilor
aici, deoarece avem deja multe resurse excelente
inclusiv o prelegere de Joan Waters
vom menționa doar că circuit-ul este construit din
un set de linii numite fire care reprezintă qubits
precum și gates care reprezintă operații pe stări cuantice
și un set de măsurători
un alt concept important din modelul de programare
pentru
aceste primitive reprezintă cele mai populare sarcini
pe care utilizatorii încearcă să le realizeze cu calculatorul cuantic
există două primitive disponibile în acest moment
Sampler și Estimator — Sampler îți oferă posibilitatea
de a eșantiona o stare pregătită de un quantum circuit
iar Estimator îți permite să estimezi valoarea de așteptare a
unui observable pentru un sistem în starea pregătită de quantum
circuit-ul tău — ultimul concept
despre care vom vorbi în această secțiune
este transpilarea — transpilarea
este procesul de rescrierea unui circuit de intrare dat
pentru a se potrivi topologiei unui anumit dispozitiv cuantic
specific
pentru execuție pe calculatoare cuantice cu zgomot
similar cu compilatoarele clasice
o rutină de transpilare modifică treptat
structura circuit-ului prin aplicarea unui set de pași
acum să vorbim despre modelele de programare clasice
există multe modele de programare
pentru calculatoarele clasice
dar în acest capitol ne vom concentra pe două
cele mai populare — programarea paralelă
și task workflow — folosind aceste două modele
în combinație cu modelele de programare cuantică
se poate exprima aproape orice flux de lucru hibrid
cuantic-clasic, de orice complexitate
modelul de programare paralelă
împarte un program în subprobleme care pot fi executate
în același timp — există două paradigme principale de programare paralelă
paralelismul cu memorie partajată și paralelismul cu memorie distribuită
pentru scopurile noastre, să ne concentrăm pe modelul cu memorie distribuită
un model cu memorie distribuită
folosește procese independente pe core-uri separate
sau noduri, unde fiecare proces are propria memorie
iar comunicarea se realizează prin message passing — există
câteva concepte care vor fi utile de știut
primul este procesul
care este o instanță independentă a programului
care rulează pe un core separat
de asemenea rank-ul, care este un identificator unic al procesului
și apoi există single program
multiple data — modelul de abstractizare
care este un model de abstractizare
pentru calcul, unde o singură instanță a programului
este distribuită pe mai multe noduri
astfel codul sursă este același
dar datele de pe acele noduri sunt diferite
execuția în modelul de programare paralelă
se desfășoară în felul următor
un singur program se distribuie pe mai multe noduri
și pornește mai multe procese paralele
fluxul de control al programului este dictat de rank
sau de identificatorul procesului
iar comunicarea se face
prin message passing
un model de programare task workflow
abstractizează calculul într-un graf sau DAG
unde fiecare nod al grafului este o sarcină specifică
sau job, iar muchiile sunt dependențe de date
și de ordine — exemple pot fi găsite în documentația noastră
la urma urmei, secvența despre care vorbim mereu în cuantică
mapare, optimizare
execuție și post-procesare
este un model de programare task workflow
unde toate sarcinile sunt executate una după
alta în pipeline
dar cu task workflows
nu suntem limitați la ordinea de execuție secvențială
și putem executa sarcini în paralel
fiecare sarcină sau workflow poate fi un job paralel complet
de sine stătător, deci poți combina
aceste modele pentru a descrie algoritmi
de orice complexitate.
Hai să încercăm să aplicăm câteva dintre conceptele pe care le-am învățat
în cod — mai întâi vom încerca să rulăm un simplu hello world
folosind paradigma programării paralele
vom folosi Open MPI
care este implementarea protocolului MPI
standardul pentru message passing
în programarea paralelă
mai întâi trebuie să avem programul pregătit
aici folosim mpi4py
care este binding-ul Python
pentru MPI, și cum poți vedea, folosim rank-ul pentru a decide
fluxul de control al programului
acum să verificăm scriptul de trimitere.
Cum poți vedea, vom folosi două noduri
un task per nod în partiția normală
și hai să rulăm programul — așteptăm puțin
și putem verifica rezultatele job-ului nostru
cum poți vedea, avem log-urile de ieșire ale programului
am folosit două noduri și două procese
identificate prin rank
cum poți vedea în output
rank zero și rank unu, care au fost folosite pentru a decide
fluxul de control al programului
cum poți vedea, procesul rank zero a trimis
un payload procesului rank unu
iar procesul rank unu a acceptat
acel payload — hai să vorbim și despre task workflows
există instrumente numite
sisteme de management al workflow-urilor — sunt special concepute
pentru a rula workflow-uri complexe
dar ca să nu te supraîncarcăm, vom folosi funcția built-in
de dependențe din Slurm
pentru a construi aceste grupuri computaționale
mai întâi trebuie să avem sarcinile workflow-ului
pregătite — acesta este același cod
avantajul de a avea fiecare dintre aceste sarcini
— mapare, optimizare, execuție
post-procesare — ca pași separați
este că putem specifica cerințe de resurse unice
pentru fiecare sarcină — de exemplu, maparea, optimizarea
și post-procesarea nu necesită
acces la resurse cuantice
prin urmare le putem rula pe partiția clasică.
Dar sarcina de execuție va necesita
resurse cuantice, deci o vom rula pe partiția cuantică
partiție.
Acum hai să folosim funcția de dependențe pentru a înlănțui sarcini
într-un workflow.
Cum poți vedea, rulăm în continuare
comanda sbatch cu flag-ul --parsable
care va returna job ID-ul
și apoi putem pasa acest job ID
ca dependință pentru alte sarcini
sau job-uri — cum poți vedea, rulăm
job-uri în workflow cu dependința
odată ce întregul workflow este complet, putem verifica rezultatele.
Și cum poți vedea, avem valoarea de așteptare înapoi.
Și putem verifica și toate
rezultatele din fiecare pas.
Care sunt și ele aici.
Și asta e tot pentru secțiunea despre modelele de programare
în capitolul următor vom vorbi despre algoritmi
avansați